- But I had no idea,
everyone make fun of me now,
I had no idea who your parents were.
- (laughs)
- Right, not everybody does.
- Until last night,
until last night,
I was like why they keep
talking about the Mamas
and the Papas and the Beach Boys?
I was like I love the Mamas and the Papas
and the Beach Boys, I was like,
what does this have to do with,
and I was like, what?
I was like, I had no idea,
I just want you to know,
on your own merit, I was there,
and it had nothing to do
with parents or anything,
and I think that that's kinda something.
To grow up, and I imagine
that was very hard,
I'm gauging and navigating
that with my kids,
I'm sure you have to as well,
but being in the public eye,
having parents so famous,
and trying to navigate
that, and what is normal,
and how do I?
- There was no normal.
- It's so hard.
- That was our normal, chaos.
- I know, that's not good.
- Well,
- Says my therapist.
- Yeah, right,
but we also have a great mom, Marylin,
who's in the audience
today, our mother Marylin.
But she was really
great at keeping it steady
and being real about things.
Not everything is normal, what is normal?
Building our self esteem as
people, and showing us love.
And now we instill that in our kids.
It's important.
- Yeah,
it's a weird thing to
navigate, but I know,
since finding that out, I kind
of read in the thing that,
one of you was put to
bed by Sir Elton John?
- Uh huh, yeah.
- And I was like, what?
(laughs) What is your life? That's insane.
What was he doing at your house.
- He just did a lullaby or something?
I don't get it, what?
- No, no, no,
he reminded me, when I was
just on The Talk with him,
a couple years ago that,
"Don't you remember I put you to sleep?"
And I'm like, what?
- I was like, no, but I'm
telling everyone (laughs)
- Yeah, exactly.
He literally came, well he
wanted to buy Dad's piano,
that Dad wrote Good Vibrations
on, that was his mission.
- Solid piano.
- Solid piano,
lot of memories there,
and he wanted this piano.
He came over, and he was
probably begging for it,
my mom said "No,"
but I guess I came downstairs
when they were chatting
and doing their thing, and he
said "Time to go back to bed,"
and put me in my bed, and that was it,
Elton John put me to sleep.
- Okay, the best part, it
turns out, of this story,
actually isn't that,
it's the fact that your mom was like
"No, you can't have our piano."
- I know.
- To Elton John (laughs)
- Well guess what, that piano's mine now
so I'm very very happy.